- Ooh sausage! (crew person laughs)
Oh (beep) we're rolling.
(upbeat horn music)
Welcome back to Tasty's Making It Big.
I'm Alvin and I make large versions
of some of America's most beloved foods.
And today we are going to
be making a huge version
of the classic McDonald's McGriddle.
I actually grew up never
eating one of these,
I was given hash browns and
orange juice by my parents
because they were healthier, they said.
That's definitely not true!
You know how much fat is in those things?
I'm going to relive my childhood
nostalgia or lack thereof
by making a large McGriddle!
Enough said, let's get started.
(jazzy bass music)
As I've been told,
a McGriddle starts with
a pancake like bun,
so we're going to make giant pancake.
This may or may not be the same way
that they do make it at the golden arches,
if they do let me know,
I'm actually curious of how they're made.
(forcefully whisking liquids)
Milk and I'm spilling, good job, dude.
Flour, baking soda, sugar and salt
and golden whisk for the golden arches.
Good one, Alvin.
(upbeat jazz music)
Don't want too many lumps in here.
(wet ingredients slopping together)
Whoo!
All right, let's get in this butter.
Double whisk, double whisk. (laughs)
It's like rubbing your
belly and patting your head.
I can do that actually.
Good job. (audience clapping)
I wonder if there's like a life scenario
in which that'll actually come in handy.
I don't know, maybe like squid
game or something like that.
Batter's looking good.
Nice and battered.
(metal whisks clanging on metal bowl)
And this is going into
quite a large pancake pan,
it's over there, see you
guys like 20 feet from here.
So I forgot to add something.
The McGriddle apparently
has a lot of syrup infused into the bun.
That's pretty, man, probably
just poured in like $30
into this bun right here.
I've been informed that this batter
is the same amount of batter
used to make around 60 pancakes,
and this is only one of the buns,
so this McGriddle is gonna be
approximately 120 times the
size of a normal one! (laughs)
In here we have quite a large pan,
pancakes should go in a hot pan,
this has been roughly preheated.
Yeah, there we go, nice sizzle.
That's good, that's good!
Grandpa told me, try not
to waste, so I won't.
Do my best grandpa.
Back in you go, dude, this
will cook until it's ready.
I'm going to make a big sausage thing now!
(upbeat jazzy bass)
What is under this bowl, you might ask?
Well, we have approximately
20 pounds of ground pork.
This is a lot of meat
and we're going to make
the sausage out of this
and to do this, we're going
to need a lot of seasoning.
Lots of seasonings,
garlic, onion powder, ground
sage, thyme, a lot of thyme,
salt, pepper and brown sugar.
Honestly, I think sugar and
savory foods are underrated
and often missed, but they
can make the big difference
between what tastes really
good and what tastes just okay.
Just like salt in desserts
is also quite underrated.
This is probably also why
the McGriddle tastes great
because there's syrup in the bun,
there's sugar in the patty,
there's probably sugar
in a lot of other things as well.
So ground pork, the one we have,
has a good amount of fat content
and that's one of the reasons
why sausage tastes good,
but this sausage is as mixed as it can.
Honestly, it does smell good.
All right, we gotta get
you into our big cake pan.
Do not handle your newborn like this.
(meat slaps onto pan)
(baby cries)
Yeah, definitely don't handle
your newborn like this.
(exaggerated grunting)
Who needs a rumble when you got this?
Fun fact, I'm actually pretty
good at giving massages
because growing up my
parents would always ask me
to give them a massage
at the end of the day,
because they were tired and
overtime I got quite good
at knowing how to massage correctly.
Some people think, "Oh, you just?"
(exaggerated pounding)
No, you can't do that.
You actually have to go like this
and you don't make your fingers firm,
you have to let your fingers be loose.
And a massage is more
than just doing this,
you got to do it the right way,
because if you hit the
wrong spots, it hurts!
So I'm giving this sausage
patty a little bit of massage.
All right, into the oven we go!
(pained grunt) Oh, it's heavy!
Somebody order a pizza? Whoo!
Oh, what's up, you little pancake?
Here you have a buddy to keep
you company in that oven.
Oh man, it's looking good.
All right, peace out. Have
a good time, be friends.
(upbeat jazz music)
A McGriddle has signature
fluffy egg square,
and we are going to make the
same exact thing, but big.
So 24 eggs gonna get destroyed!
(immersion blender whirring)
Die! Die you yolks!
(energetic heavy metal music)
(beep)
Ooh, that was fun.
Heavy cream, make it fluffy, and salt.
One more time into this machine of death!
(immersion blender whirring)
I like this.
Oh, all right, thank you!
Honestly, one of the most
underrated tools in the kitchen
the immersion blender
solves a lot of problems,
turns them into smooth solutions.
Into a tray, this is 24 eggs,
we're gonna be making
two of these because,
well this is not making it average,
(upbeat horn music)
gotta make it big!
Into some parchment, make my
life easier for the removal.
Into the oven we go, yet again!
(upbeat jazz music)
So, the fourth and final component
that we have for our McGriddle today
is the giant cheese slice.
It could be easy to throw cheese
slices on top of the thing
and call it a day, but this
isn't, you know, Making It Lazy.
(upbeat horn music)
So we're going to make our own version
of an American cheese slice,
and that starts with gelatin
and milk, getting bloomed here.
You might recall this technique being used
from the previous season where
we made a giant Krabby Patty.
And if you did, you would
be right, 10 points to you.
While the gelatin blooms,
we're going to heat up
some milk and some butter.
This is a nice glass,
where'd you get this glass?
This glass may or may not disappear
within the course of the next three days.
Some butter, in goes the
gelatin-bloomed mixture.
I believe I've seen this
method used on other websites
and people that are really good with food,
such as Serious Eats, J. Kenji López-Alt.
Really cool technique to make you own
American style cheese with other cheeses,
which makes a lot of sense,
and I like burgers, so if I
wanted to make a fancy burger,
I'll probably do this.
This is more cheddar than
I have in my bank account,
that's okay, we'll talk about that later.
(metal tool tapping against glass)
Some salt. (blender whirring)
I'm very prone to spilling,
so we're going to actually
not do something stupid!
We'll make the smart decision.
(countdown timer ticking)
(blender whirs) (plastic snaps)
Oh! No, it's good, I'll go the other way.
As you can see, I'm
very prone to spilling.
Yeah.
(machine mixing liquids)
That's a sound!
I'll get in there and scrape
down the sides real quick.
Ooh! That's looking nice, you
guys see that? (small laugh)
I'll scrape down the side.
That is satisfying, wow!
Now gotta get it on to here.
Look at that, that's some
thick, smooth cheese!
You guys ever heard of Velveeta?
Or the nacho cheese you
get at the bowling alley
with your chips?
Those are good.
Spread this guy. Ooh, ooh! That's nice.
Ooh, that's nice, I like that a lot.
Oh, so smooth! Damn!
It's like frosting a cake,
but there's no cake, frosting is cheese,
so it's actually not like
frosting a cake at all,
it's just really satisfying to do.
It's also kind of like a race against time
because you've got to get it
before the cheese starts to set,
but it's feeling pretty good,
looking really good! Whoo!
All right, I'm gonna call it.
This is gonna be our large cheese slice.
And this is going in to the fridge.
(upbeat jazz music)
(Alvin pained grunting)
I think it's time we can
build this giant McGriddle.
We got a bun, we got a patty,
and we have two sheets of
eggs, two sheets of cheese,
with a little alley-oop
from the culinary team,
I think it's time we build.
Let's see how this bun looks like.
Wait (scoffs) it's going to flip
and it's going to hit me in the face.
Here we go.
(laughs) Hold on, my brain
can't work right now.
(pan slamming onto cutting board)
Whoo! Ooh, that's a nice one.
Look at that, it's all shiny and nice.
Okay, so this'll be our top bun.
(energetic jazz music)
All right, no bun
crackage, that's all good.
So you got to get the cheese slices out.
Let's give a little trim first.
Now let's get this guy on there.
There we go, now that's a
cheese slice! (chuckles)
Okay, this is a heat gun, it
helps melt things on this show.
(heat gun fan blowing)
Ooh, that's hot.
We'll be right back. (laughs)
(triumphant horn music)
It's getting a little melty!
(exaggerated sniffing)
It does smell good.
I'm also counting on
the heat from this patty
to continue melting it, so here we go.
Whoo! Oh boy, time for the eggs.
Whoo! That's one, this is two.
Oh man, that's pretty cool.
All right, and the final shiny top bun.
I got it, yeah.
This is sturdy, nice!
Ooh, that's a McGriddle! (laughs)
While McDonald's seems
to have their signature
on every single McGriddle,
well, you know, I like
to put my name on things,
so I want to see if we
can dot in a little A.
Get nice pattern going it.
Look at that, that's
an A, or that's a line.
Oh, this is going to be delicious.
Look how much syrup we're
putting in this thing.
Nobody tell my doctor.
Just kidding, he'll
going to see the video.
Oh, you could see it in
the top down! Let's go!
This is not a Mc-Griddle,
this is A-Griddle,
'cause there's A on it!
This is a normal McGriddle,
this is A-Griddle.
As you can see, there's
quite a big size difference.
Okay, let's bisect this
guy and see what we've got.
Here we go, straight down the middle.
(exaggerated huffing)
Whoo! Oh, heck yeah.
Pardon me while I don
my protective measures,
and here we go!
Whoo! That cross section!
A double egg layer, some nicely
cooked sausage, still juicy,
and the cheese!
That's pretty cool.
All right, I'll take a honorary wedge.
One slice is bigger than the whole thing.
Cheers.
Okay, I'm gonna have to eat
this in like three bites
to get all the flavor.
(whimsical string music)
(speaking with mouthful)
Better than I thought!
I think the key to this
whole thing is the syrup.
The syrup is what makes
it taste and smell like
what I think this tastes like.
Wait, I haven't had this one, hold on.
(laughs) It's like the
same thing, but big!
Also take a little wedge of this.
Let's see.
(speaking with mouthful)
This tastes so similar!
This is the same thing.
That's really cool!
(energetic horn music)
Good job, Alvin.
Well, that was quite fun.
It's a good thing that I
do like eating what I make,
because it seems like I'll be having
lunch, breakfast and dinner
for quite a long time.
I can feel all the sugar
getting to my blood vessels
and I haven't had this much
sugar in quite a while,
so I'm going to go and maybe run it off.
I'll see you guys in
the next episode, peace!
(energetic horn music swells)